a report from Kentucky says the FBI may
be looking into controversial pardons
made by former Republican governor Matt
Bevin lawmakers from both parties say
they're concerned that some of Bevins
last-minute pardons before he left
office were favors to supporters Don
Dahler spoke to a mother who wishes she
was warned that her daughter's rapist
was going free so Don how many people
were pardoned
well Bevin granted more than 400 Pardons
and commutations some went to convicted
murderers another went to a man who
served less than two years for the rape
of a nine year old but his lawyer tells
us he's innocent he says the governor
got it right and the pardon was not bots
it just felt like a slap in the face
felt like a ton of bricks hit me I just
kind of collapsed to the floor sobbing
and crying this mother who asked us to
conceal her identity to protect her
family says she was given no warning
that Micah shuttle the man convicted of
repeatedly sexually assaulting her
daughter was going free I wish Bevin
want to come and talk to me first before
he gave Mike a pardon and that was never
done
shuttles served just 19 months of a 23
year sentence I was shocked to hear that
he was even considering a pardon for
Micah shuttle much less granting one
Kentucky public prosecutor Rob Sanders
help put shuttle behind bars this was a
very very lengthy case that was
litigated heavily to hear that he was
basically erasing all the work that we
had done was just shocking in a radio
interview last week Bevin a father of
nine defended his pardon of shuttle by
claiming there was no physical evidence
if you have been repeatedly sexually
violated as a small child by an adult
there are going to be repercussions of
that physically and medically a 2012
study found that about 90% of child
victims don't show physical evidence of
abuse this isn't a Democrat prosecutor
coming after a Republican governor I was
a supporter of Matt Bevins but what he
has done is just absolutely wrong the
problem is he's granted hundreds of
pardons to people with little or no
research into who they are what they did
or whether or not they've turned their
lives around and are worthy of a pardon
as for the victim's family
I think my daughter's going to return to
counseling because she has read Bevins
comments about her and I know it upsets
her other than that we're just kind of
taking one day at a time Sanders says
they have opened an investigation into
shuttles pardon
he says the governor's pardon file
includes letters from the defendant and
his family but nothing from the victim
police or prosecutors case they're
looking at how the case got on to the
governor's desk and if there were any
favors involved it's like victimizing
this poor girl all over absolutely
there's no doubt I mean and then to hear
the former governor say he spent
thousands of hours looking at everything
again obviously they have this power
yeah but you have to wonder especially
when it comes to this case
I mean child sexual abuse allegations
and then the man is convicted well
haven't you always wondered about the
whole concept of pardons they go through
the court system they go through the
appeals system and then a governor or a
president can pardon someone who was
convicted by their peers it's always
what there are cases where the pardons
because of evidence that was collected
during the trial and Orlais days exactly
right but this does seem disturbing and
as you point out Dana it feels like it's
revitalizing the victim and the family
here that mom there Thank You Don
you